Merry Christmas coach you got me a
present oh yeah it's tradition so
y a chimney cleaning log now you'll want
to burn that every 60 fires or so
reduces your creosol buildup by 70% and
creosol is what causes chimney fires so
you'll want to nip that in the B
kind of reminds me of my late wife
Barb we had a Christmas tradition our El
my lover and I would spend Christmas Eve
together as lovers do and we would make
love for hours in front of the fire well
there you
go I haven't
been touched by a lover since my late
wife Barb died and I miss the touch of a
lover to be
honest it's hard to find a good lover
well I'm sure you find another person
Barb was a tremendous lover she used to
say that the best part about my body was
my
legs to be honest the best part about
her was her legs too oh sounds like she
was a
wonderful woman big tits sorry you never
noticed no you never noticed Barb's
knocks
no I would lay her down at night and I
was like knock knock who's there big old
boner in my
underwear she can make an ocean fearing
man go boating well folks love boating
[Music]
so